[Music]
aloha reject nation I'm Greg Albert I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
watchmojo.com the greatest YouTube
channel in the world top 10 decisions
that ruined the movie the thumbnail is a
photo of Ryan Reynolds's Deadpool from
[Music]
Andrew Hayes
[Music]
that's cool
you should ask all our friends to make
songs for our reactions play over
that's a good way to support create a
creative community parts probably cut
out of the video
sell mojo
number ten so in Deadpool's mouth shut
x-men origins will read this ruin was
this foot ruin this movie those feelings
he's already ruined mouth why reportedly
the head of Fox that was cheesy for
Deadpool to talk during the film's
climactic showdown though Ryan Reynolds
was unhappy with how Deadpool was
perforated origins the studio
effectively made him play this version
of Deadpool or risk giving up a chance
to play the character into the future
but fortunately didn't completely fail
to do over in 2016
oh I know number not making a
live-action adaptation The Lion King oh
yeah ruined it - one point six billion
dollars the estimated 250 to 260 million
dollar budget and the vocal talents of a
multitude of high-profile actors did not
please many yes The Lion King was one of
20 19 highest-grossing movies and it
made more than 1.6 million dollars
globally but it basically hatched the
plot of the original and brought barely
anything new to the table
[Music]
when it came to making animal emotions
believable they made everything look
more weird than anything else really oh
yes good editing legacy the 1994 play
people seem to love a cinema score real
Club thanks to Bryan Singer's direction
x-men and x-men United are highly
regarded films in the franchise
however singer wasn't able to direct
this there it's gonna be like five x-men
movies on the solution macking bond with
Sonny to interact but personal reasons
caused him to back out before filming
Brett Ratner then took over and the
quality of the franchise took was agreed
upon by many fans as an immediate
downturn further adding to this film's
woes because of studio interference the
Phoenix storyline which had been built
up over the previous two films was
greatly diminished to make room for a
new plot about developing a cheer for
mutants ultimately leaving an
unsatisfying ending to the original
trilogy don't worry they fixed it with
dark Venus doe
to tell you slowly trying to replicate
the success of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Universal had ambitious plans
to build their own dark universe which
would incorporate classic villains such
as dr. Jekyll Frankenstein and The
Invisible Man
Laden don't den reject the 2017 Marissa
powder they've spent so much time trying
to build a cinematic universe they
forgot to put in effort where in most
matters the actual movie it's not exact
science this position when the money
failed to deliver at the box office
Universal had to pull the plug on the
entire project many nice never sick what
a fascinating failure that was I am
sorry considering how big they amount to
the spider you want to kill the spider
together he doesn't stand a chance
besides emo Peter the most common
complaint of spider-man 3 is its lack of
focus regarding villains whatever how
those challenges
on account of the characters lack of
humanity
so we cast Topher Grace however the
producers pressure drag me into
including venom because of the
characters popularity we can find a way
to settle this
you're so right I'm thinking humiliation
the end result was a juggling act
between venom Harry Osborn as the new
Goblin and the Sandman that came off as
painfully uneven as this film and other
superhero movies have learned to the
hard way when it comes to villains less
is in this five movies number five most
celebrity Candice's Zoolander - you
can't kill us all we will protect a
chosen one one of the highlights from
the original Zoolander was the many
memorable celebrity cameos can recapture
the same magic of the first film I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson [ __ ] well some of
these ideas worked many of them dragged
the film down hey Katie yeah it's like
when will we find out who we really are
everyone agreed that Zoolander 2 wasn't
as good as the first and into the movie
I've seen only a little more than its
budget unfortunately celebrity cameos
don't automatically translate - laughs
or ticket sales to do
Peter
[Music]
number four maybe unhappy with Batman
Returns under performing at the box
office
studio executives at Warner Brothers
decided to replace Tim Burton this was
seen as a move to tone down on the
violence that was found in Burton's
Batman films and make something that
wasn't as dark boy Joel Schumacher was
brought in to direct Batman Forever the
end result was certainly lighter but a
tip the scales to the point of being
full-blown camp everything from the sets
to the acting was outlandish and these
issues only got worse with the next film
in the series Batman and Robin I am
cell-made and I've come to make your
life a living hell the franchise
essentially collapsed under the weight
of its own silliness CGI suit Green
Lantern
[Music]
to be fair there probably was no single
factor that derailed this film its
failure was the cumulative result of
many bad decisions you should have said
that whoa Danny GI effect like overused
and unconvincing in interviews Green
Lantern and star Ryan Reynolds said he
hated the CGI suit in part because he
reportedly didn't even know what he
would look like as the Green Lantern
until the movie's premiere the infamous
suit would later become a punchline in
Reynolds next major superhero outing
2016 Deadpool please don't make the
supersuit green or animated number two
subverting all expectations Star Wars
Episode eight the last Jedi Stiles
ignites it
enemy sure Star Wars has made mistakes
in the past such as George Lucas's
decision to introduce Anakin Skywalker
as a little boy in Phantom Menace or
created character is insufferable as
charger be so excited to talk about the
last Jedi the last Jedi may have crossed
an even bigger line fans waited two
years after the force awakens to see how
the storylines JJ Abrams set up would be
resolved however the last Jedi director
Rian Johnson essentially tore down or
dismissed much of what JJ Abrams
established threw it out many fans were
not happy with these resolutions and as
such the last Jedi is largely seen as
the most polarizing Star Wars entry Wow
before we unveil our number one pick
here are some dishonorable mentions I
made any left
whoo but I'm back now then I'm gonna
make things right you really think that
they care about us general no need to
list Ben
yeah I do
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
Commissioner Gordon and Batman
commercials from nickfear all of them if
you're on your phone make sure you know
that number one Oh number one making it
a trilogy The Hobbit franchise don't
underestimate oh that's fair with his
adaptation of the Lord of the Rings
Peter Jackson was hailed as one of the
most visionary filmmakers of his
generation unfortunately when he decided
to adapt The Hobbit as a trilogy his
final product was not nearly as well
received simply put the 1937 Tolkien
story was not an epic trilogy but rather
a short novel and had no business being
adapted into three separate films says
you and Topher to stretch the source
material out Jackson had to pad scenes
by adding in stories from other Toki
quirks although there are fans who like
The Hobbit movies the overall reaction
is more mixed
whoa do you agree with our pecks let us
know in the comments and hey if you're a
fan of the song playing right now be
sure to check out the music video for it
right here
how are you
it's a body reaction being Pam okay sit
still in the corner where their arms
closed and buy the girl a drink so she
can grind up on you I'm gonna try and I
realize it wouldn't ring true well I
don't disagree with the list I don't
know which one decision ruined the whole
movie like The Hobbit one I can get on
board with I know there's a lot of
things that plagued the production of it
but I think the number one complaint
about that film is the fact that they
decided to overextend its material
you know I'm an agreeance on that I
think you know a lot of us who had heard
that del Toro wanted to make a
two-parter that sounded great and I
still wish that one day they'll reboot
it and do that well and to think that if
this had been one movie it would have
been less of an undertaking for Peter
Jackson I have to jump in at the last
minute and actually start to helm yeah
does sort of present as like from the
outset the idea yet to make it three
movies kind of touched every facet of
that production and made it yeah yeah
yeah
the thing with Fantastic Four I know
it's just an honorable mention however I
think the decision to make the last half
suddenly turn into superhero film was a
major problem with that movie I remember
when I showed Jon this film yeah well
why I showed it to you there's some
reason we were like prepping for
something it's like illogical torture I
literally cut the experience in half I
showed him the first half is a very
definitive point where they do a time
jump and then you're like okay we're in
a completely different movie and so I
cut it right before their and then we
just continue it the next day and that
first half I think is cool I like it's
like a body horror movie it's building
up to something I mean there's like
stupid science [ __ ] that they say in
there that doesn't make sense but still
whatever it's fine it's working about
that point
yeah then when they gets all spooky and
stuff and in the last half of that is
where they lost it all so I feel like
that for this question or this statement
of a decision that tanked a movie yeah I
think that decision to segue it as
quickly as you can into
superhero tale is what ruined that movie
because I'd be interested to see the
full-on committed portrait of a body
horror Fantastic Four movie because I
was on board for when I was going down
release the trick cut John no he's set
it on Twitter he'd 6 months ago I had a
cut that would have been amazing he
keeps releasing footage of it yeah I
cannot agree with The Lion King
yeah I feel like that could have worked
I just think that they didn't quite
pitch it right and also yeah like the
half the world adores this yeah I hardly
think that's a legitimately tangible
offense I mean I don't think a rotten
tomato score from a few hundred critics
outweighs the thousands that get to vote
for an audience score and a cinema score
and the box office
like those drastically outweigh whatever
the few hundred critics have to say
because I mean you and I were both like
kind of on the same page about that
movie that we felt it a little Hollow
while there's a lot to admire it's not I
agree with all the criticisms I do but I
can't be here saying like yeah it ruined
the movie because people love the movie
yeah and it's not an experiment I think
they should never have tried or
something and while I think it is a
legitimate gripe to say that it doesn't
bring anything quote new to the Lion
King part of what I wanted or expected
was just that it hits the same rough
experience with its new text so yeah
it's not a complete landing but I hardly
think that that decision demolished that
movie for any reason yes so much
impressive work on this play still you
know what did this video come out
October 2019
you know Dark Phoenix I think deserves
to be on this list more than x-men the
last time oh really oh hands let's hear
it hot take me easily man I mean hot
take like tonight red is the lowest
reviewed one in the whole franchise last
stand I think is the most disappointing
because it came right after x2 we didn't
know how long the franchise would go
this was still kind of pitched as the
final film and the
Rolla G and to this day we haven't had
like an x-men for ya just a nouns of
subtitle x-men ya know or spin-offs or
whatever this one was like yeah is the
most disappointing but I think Dark
Phoenix I'd argue more for having the
guy who the last and have his
directorial debut be the Dark Phoenix
storyline again give him a second shot I
had hope and faith cuz that's all I
could operate off of I also totally got
what everyone was saying with maybe we
shouldn't get the same guy to do this
movie people seem to really oppose to
Simon Kinberg helming that movie from
yeah sentimental point of view I feel
like if this x-men 3 was supposed to
have Dark Phoenix be as focus and then
got retooled to the you know mutant cure
scenario I'm not a hundred percent
against the idea of like yeah take a
crack at it and make your complete take
at the same time I feel like the truth
bad decision of that movie was to go
let's just do this in one movie right
they said this movie is on the list
because it's replacing Bryan Singer so
I'm taking this from a director
standpoint back then I mean Brett Ratner
didn't have some signature style but he
was making good movies he's made red
dragon which was good well these guys
are awful yes yes however at the time
Brett Ratner at least had experience
directing true side was it a good
decision
definitely not well what's a worse
decision if you're gonna include two
x-men movies on here
I think Dark Phoenix was the worst
decision however he did have a lot of
experience he's produced all the x-men
films at writing credit and a lot of
them maybe it was a chance for him to
redeem himself and learn from his
mistakes so maybe it wasn't the worst
decision I can see how that decision
could have seemed like an all right one
whereas like plugging Brett Ratner and
in his little to me like huh he's gonna
make the next x-men movie and and I
think that's also maybe unfair because I
don't know how much sway he had over the
story and I feel like the big issue of
x-men 3 yeah is that decision to have
the mutant cure story I feel like that's
what pissed people off the most aside
from sly
Dark Phoenix I can't wait for twenty
years from now when we're talking about
Tom Cruise's the month oh the classic
that is such a fascinating thing that we
all saw on bold and Johnny Depp's
Invisible Man and Javier Bardem
Frankenstein and Angelina Genoa they're
all shot they're all a shot at least the
dark universe releases that Alex
Kurtzman hire whoever was helming this
yeah I feel like that's a good call
because it seemed to tank their entire
thing that they just went so gung-ho and
they're like people want an hour on
board for this dark universe we're not
even gonna try it out first
yeah our first trial with Dracula told
was not successful but hey let's go for
it it's like a restaurant that a bunch
of celebrities throw so much buy-in to
promote and then they have this big
grand opening and they shut it down just
a complete failure feels like a bunch of
famous people were in red with the whole
cast Oh like this is the future we got
filmmakers line up the next one is
invisible Bride of Frankenstein and it's
beautiful I love it that's why she did
Maleficent - mm-hmm look out now I can't
speak on Zoolander - all I know is that
Justin Bieber thing looked pretty funny
to me I mean Zoolander's whatever I mean
just used to me celebrity cameos I bet
there was more that plague that I don't
think that was would take that yeah
switching from Tim Burton to Joel
Schumacher yeah more with that it seemed
like Joel Schumacher what he did was
more in service for what the studio
wanted to take it - Batman Returns has
seen evident by a minor moment here it's
a very dark movie not for children I
love that film though I don't like
Batman Forever a hard time sitting
through that film it's very annoying
okay how do I kind of enjoyed that man
down ROM because this is so awful that I
did enjoy it and you have the primer of
Batman Forever to come out of a Batman
Forever just annoying yeah but that begs
the question of it was it Joel
Schumacher's fault was it his version of
their studio not've this is what they
want or
it would have been this way regardless I
mean I don't know I have a hot take oh I
do not like Jim Carrey as the Riddler
that bit only works if you shut the door
on my way back I feel like maybe Jim
Carrey's Riddler was good for back then
ie people didn't seem as anal about the
accuracy of the depictions I like cuz
I've heard it ain't even about that I
just think he's so annoying and that
like I watched it again I think last
year and I like he's not funny in it
he's just loud annoying just Jim he's
not a character to me he's Jim Carrey
with no filter it's like entertained
whatever whim you want Jim yeah just
kind of say there's a lot of things
wrong with that movie I mean I don't
like Tommy Lee Jones in it either I see
why people like his Riddler I do I
personally I just I'm so irritated when
I watched but maybe that's what's more
palatable about Batman and Robin is that
poison ivy and Mr Freeze and Bane are
more palatable and enjoyable to watch
then the Riddler and two-face yeah sure
man universe hey Star Wars the last Jedi
just sweet on to talk about the same war
okay fine you win I agree with
everything us a film sucks it's not a
good movie I hate it I think what ruined
it maybe not having a three movie plan
first that's what ruins if anything not
at all cueing and Rian Johnson on some
of these mysteries of what the answers
really are maybe reading the room a
little bit
ruined it was them not understanding
lore and Disney just being like I want
to make money maybe we'll get some clout
will being like hey create a filmmaker
step in whoopsy and get JJ back in here
to fix this for us
whoa Lord and Miller what are you doing
oh my good you not see what happen the
last Jedi when we just let him take the
rain so you're Ron Howard in here the
last Jedi is in the Batman V Superman's
of the world make me fear for when big
studios are like no no we're gonna put
our faith in a creative and I'm like
that guy's got a lot of talent but
sometimes I guess you got to be
conscientious about how you do that
because hey I mean Joker
nailed it yeah I know and that's the
alchemy there's I mean you freaky you
could do something different I just
think when you go again
what has been established I don't care
anymore let's watch Rises Skywalker
there will be good Star Wars again in
the future of some variety alright guys
well thanks for being here hey Star Wars
you guys can subscribe to watchmojo.com
because describe the real rejects click
notification belts for us and Andrew
Hayes thanks so much dude and room I
wanted to point something out to you
you're not one of those people who
doesn't message me back patreon oh you
do message me best but what I noticed is
I'll sometimes ask you questions and you
just flat-out don't answer or respond
with a message back to those questions
and instead say something else and if
you want to be a better communicator you
got a you know respond to things someone
is saying you can't just change the
subject this isn't name of just some
like verbal you know we're on the phone
or so this is you've read it stop a void
and then you type but you'd like I don't
want to confront tell Greg what I
thought of the Joker even though I asked
him what he thought of the Joker why are
you being this way he's collecting
research on people's feelings about the
Joker
it's not about Andrew at all
okay you know it's okay it's okay your
opinion matters and that's what counts
yeah Andrews here for you I used to
think my opinion matter doesn't matter
didn't touch them that you know Andrew
loves you and that's that's all that
really matters I mean you just got to
remind yourself of that and hey he's a
busy guy but you're his one you know I
bet he sits around all day touching
himself too real rejects videos I'm not
busy there we upload a few times a day
plus you know on patreon and stuff you
know all those TV show watch the lungs
and you know the other cuts wiggly
reaction Hilah that's right and there's
the reaction highlights except swiping
weekly Q&A weekly Q&A s I mean the music
videos sometimes and then like the other
things like pictures are behind the
scenes stuff our lens stories are
Stardust reactions all those different
movies we've been posting 30-second
reactions to and if you follow us first
that's how the app knows that we sent
you to do that or maybe like how when we
work with point master oh yeah coin
master download the game find the Star
Wars a Jedi after battle where's trailer
reaction and download the app there and
get yourself some free stuff by a ridge
wallet loved the Ridge Ridge calm slash
reject nation I think we got more
sponsors - Lane go download - Lane love
the - lighthouse oh I get it